welcome back everybody it's time for
this week's pet project lori karen joins
us from the nspca and she brought along
someone who needs a safe and caring home
and i hear it's a cat named little lamb
how cute
hi rocky this is a little
beautiful five-year-old brown tabby she
is healthy she was a transfer from
another local shelter and she does have
stomatitis which is a condition that um
is not severe we will it's an
inflammation of the gums and we actually
have a program at nevada spca which we
will pay for um the treatments which is
usually a quarterly injection uh she is
on a special diet too which we recommend
but she's the best part about little
lamb is she's very affectionate and
she's very
cool and you know that people love it
when cats purr it's so calming and she's
doing that right now oh and she's
meowing she loves you
and she loves to play
well speaking of playing what kind of
family would would little lamb do best
with
so we know she does well with other cats
we know she does well with older kids so
she really has a could be a good fit for
a lot
people that are good this afternoon uh
she's and she'll play with anything so
anybody who wants a cat that will be a
lot of fun in their household and they
have a lot of cat toys to play with
little lamb would be a great fit for
that family that's too precious her name
reminds me of lamb chops play along but
i might be aging myself that's so cute
all right so how can people how can
people that are interested get in touch
with you guys and adopt little lamb
so we're still doing adoptions by
appointment at nevada spca so just go to
our website make an appointment and
indicate that you're interested in
little lamb and our adoption team we'll
connect with you and talk to you all
about little lamb and whether she'll be
a good fit for your family perfect and
little lamb along with so many other
animals tell us about the neon dog walk
i hear about
all right so nevada sbc is really
excited to launch our first ever neon
dog walk on saturday october 9th at
sunset park we just launched it this
week so for anybody out there who wants
a wonderful
early evening walk with their dog with
all kinds of festivities of food and
beverage and entertainment there's more
information on our website and you can
register there as well it's of course a
fundraiser for nevada spca you know we
rely entirely on the generosity of the
community but it's also a great
opportunity for you to enjoy some great
time with your family and friends and of
course your dog at neon dog walk october
9th that is so cute we'll also have more
information on that at eightnewsnow.com
it sounds like a little doggy music
festival i love that
exactly yeah the perfect saturday night
perfect okay thank you so much lori if
you're interested in adopting a pet go
to
nevadaspca.org or just call them at
702-873-7000